alors pour répondre à votre question
pourquoi c'est uniquement un projet
économique et si vous regardez le slide
numéro 11 c'est à dire 3 side plus tard
voilà celui ci dans celui ci voit là
vous voyez que dans le monde le secteur
des médias c'est le deuxième secteur le
plus rentable après le luxe donc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent dans les médias et donc une
autre intérêt n'est pas politique n'est
pas idéologique c'est un intérêt
purement économique et depuis vingt ans
ce groupe s'est constitué uniquement sur
des questions économiques et vous avez
vu d'ailleurs si c'était politique le
segment de l'information pour nous est
un segment absolument un signifiant à la
fois en chiffre d'affaires chez nous
mais dans le poids du pays c'était le
slide que je vous ai montré en numéro 3
ou 4 où on s'aperçoit que nous sommes
minuscule
[Musique]